أمطار غزيرة تتدفق بلا هوادة هذا
مقطع فيديو لمراسل ينقذ ممرضة
قبل شروق الشمس مباشرة هذا الصباح بعد
أن علقت في طريق غمرته الفيضانات
يحث المسؤولون السكان على البقاء
حيث هم طيبون ، ونرى هذا في
كثير من الأحيان الخشخاش يقولون لا تقود على
الطرق ترتفع المياه بسرعة ثم
تعلق هذه السيارات على الطرق
، يا له من شيء لا يصدق أن تراه
رائعًا يا ريان الشاب زميلنا على
الأرض في أورلاندو والذي بالطبع
يشعر بالكثير من تأثير هذه
العاصفة الآن ريان شكرًا لك
لكونك معنا ، تحدثت بالفعل إلى ذلك
المراسل ، ماذا أخبروك ،
وإذا كنت تستطيع مشاركة أسمائهم
حتى يتمكن الجميع من معرفة البطل
الذي هم عليه ،
نعم اسمه توني أتكينز ، إنه أخ جيد
أعرفه جيدًا.  حسنًا في الواقع
رأينا الفيديو ورأينا ذلك الإنقاذ الذي
شعرنا بالدهشة ، أعني أنه انتظر
في الماء لإنقاذ تلك المرأة إذا
فكرت في الأمر ، لم تكن تقود سيارتها
في الماء فقط لأنها أرادت ذلك
للوصول إلى العمل ، فهي ممرضة حتى
تفهم تفانيها في
وظيفتها ، لا يختلف الأمر عما نحاول
القيام به هنا وهو تقديم خدمة
للناس ، لذا كانت في طريقها إلى العمل
، وكانوا يحاولون توجيهها للأسفل
لإخبارهم  يا لها ، هذه المياه تغمرها المياه ،
سنعرض لك بعضًا من هذا الفيديو مرة
أخرى وعندما علقت في تلك السيارة
أغلق توني في الماء
وخرج إليها وأخرجها أساسًا
من هذا الوضع المائي